the idea of congruence was introduced to
the world by Gauss in the early 18th
century you've heard of him before I
think he's responsible for some work on
magnetism also and it turns out that
this idea after several centuries
remains an active field of application
and research and in particular it in
computer science it's used significantly
in crypto which is what we're going to
be leading up to now in this unit it's
also plays a role in hashing which is a
key method for managing data in memory
but we are not going to go into that
application anyway the definition of
congruence is real simple congruence is
a a relation between two numbers a and B
it's determined by another parameter n
where n is considered to be greater than
1 all of these as usual are integers and
the definition is simply that a is
congruent to B mod n if n divides a
minus B or a minus B is a multiple of n
so that's a key definition to remember
there's other ways to define it will see
very shortly an equivalent formulation
that could equally well have been used
as a definition but this is a standard
one a is equivalent to B means that a
minus B is a multiple event well let's
just practice 30 is equivalent to 12 mod
9 because a 30 minus 12 is 18 and 9
divides 18 okay an immediate application
is that this number with a lot of six is
ending in a three is equivalent to 788
253 modulo 10 now why is that well
there's a very simple reason if you
think about subtracting the six number
ending in three from the seven number
ending in three what you can immediately
see without doing much of any of the
subtraction just do the low order digits
um when you subtract these you're going
to get a number that ends in zero which
means that it's divisible by ten
and therefore those two numbers are
congruent it's very easy to tell when
two numbers are congruent mod 10 because
they just have the same lower or digit
okay another way to understand
congruence and what it's really all
about is the so called remainder lemma
which says that a is kind of going to be
mod n if and only if a and B have the
same remainder on division by n so let's
work with that definition we can
conclude using this formulation
equivalent formulation that xxx is
equivalent to 12 mod 9 because the
remainder of 30 divided by 9 loads it's
3 times 9 is 27 remainder 3 and the
remainder of 12 by 9 is 3 so they do
indeed have the same remainder 3 and
their Congress by the way the this sign
of this equivalent sign with the three
horizontal bars is red is both
equivalent and congruent and I will be
bouncing in fact between the two
pronunciations indiscriminately they're
synonyms ok let's think about proving
this remain dilemma just for practice
and in order to fit on this slide I'm
going to have to abbreviate this idea of
the remainder of B / n with the shorter
notation R sub BN just to fit okay so
the if direction of proving the
remainder lemma that they're congruent
if and only if they have the same
remainder the if direction here in if
and only if is from right to left is
that I've got to prove that if they have
the same remainder then they're
congruent so there are the two numbers
by a and B by the division a theorem or
division algorithm they can each be
expressed as a quotient of a divided by
n times the quotient a sub a plus the
remainder of a divided by n likewise B
can be expressed in terms of quotient
and remainder and what we're given here
is that the remainders are equal but if
the remainders are equal then clearly
when I subtract a minus B I get Q a
minus Q B times n sure enough a minus B
as a multiple of N and that takes care
of that one the only-- of direction
now goes from left to right so in the
converse I'm going to assume that n
divides a minus B where a and B are
expressed in this form by the division
algorithm or division theorem so if n
divides a minus B looking at a minus B
in that form what what we're seeing is
that n divides this a Q a minus Q B
times n plus the difference of the
remainders that's what I get just by
subtracting a and B but if you look at
this
um and divides that term the quotient
times n and it therefore has to divide
the other term as well because the only
way that n can divide is sum when it
divides one of the sum ends is if it
divides the other sum and so n divides
our a minus a the remainder of a divided
by n from B divided by n but remember
these are remainders so that means that
they're both in the interval from 0 to n
minus 1 inclusive and the distance
between them has got to be less than 1
so if n divides a number that's between
0 and n minus 1 that number has to be 0
because it's the only number that n
divides in there so in fact the
difference of the remainders is 0 and
therefore the remainders are equal and
we've knocked that one off so there it
is restated the remainder lemma says
that if they're they're congruent if and
only if they have the same remains and
that's worth putting a box around to
highlight this crucial fact which could
equally well have been used as a
definition of congruence and then you
prove the division definition that we
began with
now some immediate consequences of this
remain dilemma are that a congruence
inherits from a lot of properties of
equality because it means nothing more
than that the remainders are equal so
for example we can say that congruence
is symmetric meaning that if a is
congruent to B then B is congruent to a
that's obvious because akon going to be
means that a and B have the same
remainder so B and a have the same
remainder
one that would actually take a little
bit of work to approve from the division
definition not a lot of work but a
little bit would be that if a is
congruent to b and b is kind of going to
C then a is congruent to C but we can
read it as saying the first says that a
and B have the same remainder the second
says that B and C have the same
remainder so obviously a and C have the
same remainder and we've proved this
property that's known as transitivity of
congruence another simple consequence of
the remainder theorem is a little
technical result that's enormous ly
useful called the remainder lemma which
says simply that a number is congruent
to its own remainder modulo n the proof
is is easy let's prove it by showing
that a and the remainder of a have the
same remainder well if I take remainders
of both sides the left-hand side becomes
the remainder of a divided by n the
right-hand side is the remainder of the
remainder but the point is that the
remainder is in the interval from 0 to n
and that means when you take its
remainder mod and its itself and
therefore the left-hand side is the
remainder of a divided by N and the
right hand side is also the remainder of
the a divided by N and we have proved
the this corollary that's the basis of
remainder arithmetic which will
basically allow us whenever we feel like
it to replace numbers by their
remainders and that way keep the numbers
small and that also merits a highlight
okay now in addition to these properties
like equality that congruence has it
also interacts very well with the
operations which is why it's called a
congruence and congruence is a is an
equality like relation that respects the
operations that are relevant to the
discussion in this case we're going to
be talking about plus and times and the
Congress the first fact about congruence
says that if a and B are congruent then
a plus C and B plus C are congruent
the proof of that follows trivially from
the definition because the a congruent
to B mod n says that n divides a minus B
and if n divides a minus B obviously and
divides a plus C minus B plus C because
say plus C minus B plus C is equal a
minus b that one is deceptively trivial
um it's also the case that if a is kind
of going to B then a times C is kind of
going to B times C this one takes a
one-line proof we're given that n
divides a minus B that certainly implies
that n divides any multiple of a minus B
so multiply it by C and then apply
distributivity and you discover that n
divided divides AC minus BC which means
AC is kind of went to be C modulo n it's
a small step that I'm going to omit to
go from adding the same constant to both
sides to adding any two congruent
numbers to the same size so if a is kind
of going to B and C is congruent to D
then in fact a plus C is congruent to B
plus D so again congruence is acting a
lot like ordinary equality if you add
equals to equals you get equals and of
course the same fact applies to
multiplication if you multiply equals by
equals you get equals a corollary of
this is that if I have two numbers that
are congruent modulo n then if I have
any kind of arithmetic formula involving
plus and times and minus and what I want
to know is what it's equivalent to
modulo n I can figure that out freely
substituting a by a prime or a prime by
a I can replace any number by a number
that it's congruent to and the final
congruence result of the formula is
going to remain unchanged so overall
what this shows is that arithmetic
modulo n is a lot like ordinary
arithmetic and the other crucial point
though that follows from this fact about
remainders is that because a is
congruent to the remainder of a divided
by n then when I'm doing arithmetic on
congruence 'iz I can always keep the
numbers involved in the remainder
interval that is
in the remainder range from zero to n
minus one and we use this standard
closed-open notation interval notation
to mean the interval from zero to n so
this is red this is it's sometimes used
in analysis to mean the real interval of
reals but we're always talking about
integers so this means the integers that
square bracket means zero is included
and round parenthesis means that n is
excluded so it's the that's exactly a
description of the integers that are
regular equal to zero and less than n
let's do an application of this
remainder arithmetic idea suppose I want
to figure out what's 2 to the 287 to the
9th power modulo 4 well for a start if I
take the remainder of 287 divided by 4
it's not very hard to check that that's
3 and that means that 287 to the 9th is
congruent mod 4 to 3 to the Knights so
already I got rid of the 3 digit number
the base of the exponent and replaced it
just by a 1 digit number 3 that's
progress well we can make more progress
because 3 to the 9th can be expressed as
3 squared squared squared times 3 right
because when you're when you iterate
taking powers it means that the
exponents multiply so this is 3 to the 2
times 2 times 2 or 8 times 3 which adds
1 to the exponent or 9 so that's simple
exponent arithmetic but notice that
3 squared is 9 and 9 is congruent to 1
mod 4 so that means I can replace 3
squared by by 1 and it becomes the outer
two squared stays it becomes 1 squared
squared but that's 1 times 3 and the
punchline is that 287 to the 9th is
congruent to 3 mod 4 by a really easy
calculation that did not volve
involve taking anything for the 9th
power